[Aplausos]
depois de assistido mais nova de três
toques de 12 anos aqui na universidade
vai entrar ver esse tiago ser construída
e tentando pela segunda vez aqui eu
diria que é um pouquinho se instalando
aqui neste palco mais também é um
sentimento muito bom de gratidão de
poder compartilhar com vocês uma coisa
que eu tenho aprendido a um grande
equilíbrio
enquanto eu estava falando que ia falar
sobre equilíbrio nos jogos equestres no
pessoal conhece tomou pouca negar se a
falar sobre o equilíbrio precisam
entender um pouquinho vai sair
trabalhando pra caramba essa
infelizmente não é muito estudo que
ouviu falar sério em relação a uma nova
visão de equilíbrio é o tempo que está
muito em pauta nas empresas pelo
estresse que o trabalho feito a mando
das pessoas
saiba também a universidade porque os
alunos também têm muitas dúvidas sobre o
benfica se dedicar aos estudos é um
momento que significa 11
infelizmente e um gênio da face da terra
e resolver esse problema nenhum
mas a proposta poderia trazer para vocês
aqui é que a gente pudesse observar um
pouco desse tema no equilíbrio através
de uma nova visão e para que a gente
caminha de forma equilibrada nesse tema
eu dividiria a apresentação em três
passos primeiro vou falar um pouco da
minha história em relação a esse tema
a segunda parte falar um pouco de uma
pesquisa na operação a história e no
final falar sobre o presente e esse
presentes podem entender com o presente
de comer cabeça temos dias atuais
mas eu gostaria muito que isso realmente
foi um presente para vocês que vocês
pudessem levar para casa no final dos
seis minutos que a gente vai passar
muito certo pois bem vamos começar com
uma história então mas antes eu queria
fazer uma pergunta você já se depararam
com uma situação que você queria muito
comprar uma coisa mas se você gastar seu
dinheiro com aquilo e ele faltar
dinheiro no final do mês trazendo um
pouco mais com o ambiente universitário
seja aqueles muito naquela festa mas se
você gastar seu dinheiro naquela festa
você teve como macarrão instantâneo da
lei faz sentido se não fosse tava pra
comprar uma salsicha tal
deu pra entender né
a menina que está aí eu gostava sempre
acerta sempre optava pelas festas já não
tocava pelo macarrão instantâneo ela
trocava por arroz com o lateral esquerdo
com ela durante a oferta não é fábio
felício sempre bom ter uma alimentação
mais saudável do setor
mas vamos lá o que isso tem a ver com
ele
pois bem eu tava na graduação aqui o que
eu mais queria fazer depois de informar
que ela tem aquela sensação de que você
poderia esperar mercado tem na
prateleira do último a escada passar
pelo caixa de 30 que me preocupar com
dinheiro no final do mês
hoje como o doutor ou obter êxito
quando terminei a informação aqui eu
consegui realizar um desejo de vários
jovens que estão ativamente no final da
graduação
para conseguir um emprego logo após a
colação de grau
então esse emprego e todas as parcelas
da sensação de independência financeira
dos meus pais fizeram colocar bastante
entrei nesse trabalho né então dinheiro
agora mais um problema por lá pegar o
último mais cara legal leite fermentado
disco é ligado ao passar os três juntos
e não deu pra vocês transformaram ainda
essa é a melhor sensação do início e
dava a impressão que a vida estava
perfeitamente equilibrada
o trabalho tinha dinheiro pra poder não
é comparável muito lá e é e com essa
sensação de independência e colocando
cada vez mais força no trabalho mais
força e que isso quer dizer
trabalhar mais e mais horas quando você
faça mais coisas mas quer como trabalho
coisas tomam mais nada
e como você tá lá temos como executar e
falou tá dando errado que eu tô aqui pra
eu sou o problema
isso alimenta um ciclo de cada vez mais
vagas de trabalho até o momento
eu não sei precisar exatamente quando o
stress a ansiedade tomava conta de mim e
isso parece perto do equilíbrio que era
tão perfeito já não estava tão mais
perfeito assim como mais gosta que eu
colocava parece pior ficava pela
situação a que chegou o momento que
parecia que já não existia mais força na
e aí eu comecei a fazer algumas coisas
chatas e fazer discutiu com colegas da
empresa se afastar das pessoas queridas
parada na forma da empresa
mas embora tenha desistido de várias
coisas várias pessoas felizmente algumas
dessas pessoas não desistiram de mim
naqueles momentos
mas aqui mais equilíbrio ao subir
mostraram que o problema não é
exatamente a falta de força era saber de
colocar o momento elas essas pessoas
basicamente ensinava porque aí é mais
importante que seja passado por uma
situação dessa de desequilíbrio pode ser
uma situação mais agravante onde passam
bem mais simples de descanso do livro
você passar pois bem e merecia essa
situação e tem que trazer novamente de
você decidir até hoje a 10 presente
momento que a gente está tendo nesse
teatro com certeza a gente está aqui
porque nós conseguimos suportar e
superar esses desafios certo vocês
conseguem imaginar relembrar algumas
pessoas duas vezes processo lembra essa
pessoa será que essa pessoa te ensinou a
te ajudou a suportar todo peso ou uma
olhadela time mostrou que você tinha
força das era uma questão sabendo usar
cada momento excelente aprendizado por
já não é bom na base da palavra
brasileiro em que vamos lá mesmo que
esse já seria um grande aprendizado
vamos tentar entender se precisava de
uma outra forma já se pegou pensando mas
assim viajando mesmo porque é que vocês
fazem uma série de coisas que queria que
consome o seu recurso mais precioso que
é o tempo que estou fazendo isso que
estou deixando de fazer alguma coisa
nessa pegada é comum esses são os
famosos porque nas nossas vidas
nós vemos perguntando o porquê das
coisas
o equilíbrio e não é uma coisa física
que apresentava uma balança porque se
ele fosse a gente conseguia visualizar e
colocar a mochila nas costas de alguns
dados de um ano tá tudo aquilo que a
gente gosta de fazer a família casamento
para ficar nos seus corpos e do outro
lado
tudo que a gente tenha um meio que a
obrigação de fazer e fazer uma
verificação de vontade ea gente não
consegue separar a vida de uma pessoa
das 8 às 18 no resto do dia a portaria
de 80 pra fora
outros momentos de lazer dedicação e
vontade nós somos apenas um certo
nós somos essa balança e responsáveis
por todo esse querido e começa a
acreditar novamente em alta é físico
ele é representado por isso porque esse
mas da mesma forma de se supor que ficam
colocando peso que são faces da gente
equilibrar a gente também pode usar
alguns contra abusos contra - não
necessariamente quer fazer mais força
para exigir um equilíbrio mas é muitas
vezes na nossa divisão eo contrato que
eu possa ver que vocês pudessem começar
a utilizar a partir de hoje é uma coisa
muito parecida e substituiu o por quê ou
quem é que eu estou fazendo isso porque
é que estão deixando de fazer alguma
coisa porque eu estou dedicando tantas
horas no mês que o meu trabalho porque
estou deixando algumas atividades do
estudo leão cativo e dedicar a
atividades extracurriculares
é engraçado que é uma letra é uma coisa
tão sutil uma pergunta a gente tende a
fazer bem - essa pergunta já pararam
para pensar nisso
a gente pergunta muito menos porque
sendo que essa deveria ser a primeira
vez
elas estão lá porque a divisão e falou a
operação desde o momento que a gente
adora até o momento que a gente vai
dormir
nós estamos sempre tomando ações que
capta a vida de outras pessoas
se a gente começa a olhar no olho dessas
pessoas e visualiza o resultado que é
acerca das nossas ações
isso com certeza a gente traz um
equilíbrio melhor pra ela pra gente
ficou um pouquinho mais para a cidade
onde a gente passa por um presente que
de certa forma também está relacionada
aprendizado dentro é dessa área de
aprendizagem
tem uma frase que é muito chique o
afastamento seja ouvido na vida é
verdade que nós estamos sempre
aprendendo
já ouvi essa frase está sempre
aprendendo na virilha é grave mas é
verdade que na vida a gente está sempre
aprendendo
será que também na verdade que a gente
tá sempre ensinando e aprendendo aqui
também em sentido tomar consciência que
a gente pode olhar no próximo resultado
das nossas ações trazem uma sensação de
responsabilidade
em qualquer lugar que a gente for não
interessa o assunto com a sempre vamos
encontrar dois tipos de pessoas as
pessoas que sabem mais que a gente e as
pessoas que sabem menos do que a gente
muitas vezes essas pessoas que sabem
menos do que a gente é essa então olha
colocarmos porque elas quiseram
provavelmente porque elas não tiveram as
mesmas oportunidades que nós tivemos as
mesmas histórias as mesmas tse para
poder compartilhar o de ensinar essas
pessoas e compartilhar com elas um pouco
da nossa inspiração e visão de vida é
aumentar o poder delas poderia olhar
suas próprias vidas e olhar o mundo e
nos seus olhos podem ter certeza que
quem vai estar ainda maior com o pai ou
com web aconteça
somos músicos reflexo do professor
de certa forma isso traz uma
responsabilidade
se nós vamos olhar o próximo do nosso
próprio equilíbrio provavelmente
realmente também olhando pra nós
gostamos seu próprio equilíbrio então
isso nos traz a responsabilidade também
nos dedicar e conter o nosso olhar
atento feliz com as pupilas lá atrás e
orgulhosos daquilo que a gente faz no
dia a dia seja brasileiro ou o e é
difícil começar esse desafio parece
difícil começar é alguém do sul devido a
um fundo brasileiro
o sul do brasil mostrou se correta
gaúcha que ele nos ajuda muito nessa
questão de desafios quando a gente
compreende a visão dele sobre o tempo e
se pode chamar aplicada em outras
palavras do poeta nos ensina que entende
tão cara que inventou o calendário o que
o calendário sempre na onu dia nos dá
uma nova semana o novo nem se o ano
isso nos dá o presente de que o tempo
uma variável que serve sempre frente mas
eles sempre nos dá a oportunidade de
recomeçar a gente possa ir lá e começar
a cada dia e compartilhar com as pessoas
as nossas inspirações experiências que a
vida nos ensinou que ela estava presente
no presente ano hoje e que ela vai estar
a funcionar amanhã porque assim se é
verdade que na vida de estar sempre
aprendendo também é verdade que a gente
está sendo ensinado por ruriá
[Aplausos]